we can graph this one y equals x minus 2
over X in two ways I'll show you both
usually when I show you multimethods I
so I prefer this one over this one I
think this is one of the cases where you
really regardless of whether you prefer
one or the other you've got to learn
both ok and that's part of why it's
called addition and subtraction of
ordinates ok but I think as I show you
how I go through it and then you
probably able to tell which one I prefer
but I'll leave it up to you so here we
go on the left hand side because I have
the same two component functions as
before the difference is just the side
ok
I've graphed the two same component
functions actually I just left the same
graph on there okay so what do I do now
subtraction thinks in Reverse term
addition right so for instance when you
think about what's happening over here
right you ever said ok I'm going to be
close to this y equals x line but I'll
be a bit underneath right or subtraction
reverses what's happening right so
instead of going a bit underneath
because this line is negative it's a
double negative right so it's
subtracting a negative which is addition
right so I'm actually going to be above
this line this asymptotes still gonna be
in acetone but I'm gonna be above ok as
I progress towards the right towards
this vertical asymptote
what's happening I've got this line here
and I'm subtracting a very be negative
think about that subtracting a big
negative which is the same as adding a
be positive right so I'm gonna be
skyrocketing up towards the asymptote at
the top instead of at the bottom ok now
I've got a negative here a positive here
and I have no discontinuities in between
here right those discontinuities I've
gotta go from negative to positive that
means I'm passing through the axis now
waiting pass to the axis if I'm
subtracting one from another I pass to
the axis when it's at zero right that's
where the access is so I should be at
zero when these two things are equal
right when this is equal to that the
whole thing will be zero and I can see
where this is equal that it's called the
point of intersection between
so I look here and if you want you can
draw up a vertical line and I say that
point of intersection corresponds to an
intercept okay and now we've got three
points I think it's enough to see the
behavior so there's the graph on the
left hand side okay and as we noticed
before these are still the same old
functions so on the right hand side
we're going to get the same thing but
fit great so okay now unlike our
previous function this graph has
intercepts as we just pointed out okay
so you want to actually make sure you
label what those are I think if you
crunch the algebra you should get plus
or minus root 2 okay now what's the
alternative way oh yeah over here
what am I done I draw my equals x is the
same okay because that's the the
function over here but I haven't drawn
two over X I've drawn negative two over
X right so what I'm doing is I'm
considering this graph as y equals x
plus -2 over X right so even though this
it's subtraction I'm considering it as
addition right addition of just happens
to be a negative function okay so that's
why I've got these in place and now I
think in the same terms that I did in
the first example okay so for instance
down here okay y equals s this is a big
value and this is a little one so I
think about this one first here and I
have to add a little positive value so
I'm here plus a little bit right as I
get closer here both of these values are
increasing right this one's going closer
to 0 this one's going off to infinity so
it goes to infinity okay it's climbing
now where are these two going to cross
the interest beyond the axis
well this one's negative this one's
positive right so when they're roughly
the same distance roughly when they're
exactly the same distance negative and
positive they will cancel out right yep
ok so now I've got my same three points
that I did before
that's a bit wonky sorry about that
you get the idea okay I've got the same
intercept here
sorry Assam to it here and the same
that's entered there and of course
because it's odd I'm English the same
logic okay so which method you use if
you do real subtraction or if you do
cheaper subtraction which is really
addition is is up to you okay just
remember which one you are doing okay
because there's nothing worse than
starting one way and then using the
methods of another way like oh this is
positive I should add a bit like well no
this is the subtraction graph right so
you choose which one okay